78 es el 15 por ciento de que el número
y para que nosotros logremos hacer esto
vamos a reescribir esto nosotros tenemos
que el 15 por ciento de algún número no
sabemos que el número sea lo llamaremos
x va a ser igual a 78
tenemos tres datos el porcentaje la base
y la cantidad o el monto en este caso el
monto del 78 que ya lo conocemos el 15%
es el porcentaje obviamente cuál será el
número base al cual al multiplicarlo por
15% tendremos 78 para que nosotros
tengamos esta respuesta vamos a
necesitar liberar este x o despejarlo
en este caso estamos multiplicando el 15
por ese número x para que nosotros
podamos despejar esto vamos a hacer una
división pero vamos a hacerlo
de otra manera ya que tenemos
porcentajes y números enteros vamos a
pensar en lo siguiente tenemos 15 % el
cual sabemos que significa 15 de cada
100 % por cada 100 pero también
conocemos que está esta fracción la
podemos escribir como 15 centésimos y
entonces todo se vuelve mucho más
sencillo porque porque si yo divido
ambos lados
de esta igualdad vamos a hacer lo
siguiente 15
centésimos que son estos mismos 15 por
ciento si lo divido entre 15 por ciento
ya sólo me quedara la multiplicación de
x
pero lo que le haga al lado izquierdo lo
tengo que hacer también al lado derecho
así es que el 78 lo dividiré en tren
15 centésimos y con esto vamos a tener
despejada nuestra ecuación porque este
15 se elimina si yo multiplico algo por
15 por ciento y lo divido entre 15 por
ciento se elimina así es que sólo nos
quedará entonces x será igual a
38 /
15 centésimos y esto puede ser muy
sencillo si tenemos una calculadora lo
ingresamos y tenemos la respuesta pero
nosotros vamos a hacer la operación se
va a poner divertido van a ver
78 lo vamos a dividir entre 15
centésimos
y nosotros ya sabemos manejar este tipo
de operaciones sabemos que si vamos a
utilizar un decimal como divisor hemos
de multiplicar este por 100 para que
podamos convertirlo en 15 así es que
hagamos lo siguiente vamos a mover el
punto decimal hacia la derecha una dos
veces y nos quedará ahora como 15
borraré entonces este punto para que sea
más claro que ahora lo tenemos aquí pero
lo que le hacemos al divisor lo hacemos
en el dividendo también así es que vamos
a recorrer el punto decimal que se
encuentra aquí
es más colocaré los dos ceros para que
podamos
recorrerlo recorreremos entonces el
punto decimal que se encuentra aquí dos
veces hacia la derecha como lo hicimos
con el divisor y ahora se encuentra aquí
de tal manera que sepamos que 78 entre
15 centésimos es igual a 7.800 entre 15
y con eso vamos a poder hacer nuestra
división como una división larga común
vamos a empezar entonces con la división
cuántas veces nos cabe 15 en 78 si 15
por 4 es igual a 60 15 por 5 será igual
a 75 entonces nos funciona 5 por 15 es
igual a 75 sea 78 le restó 75 tendré 3
suena bastante bien ahora podemos bajar
el siguiente cero recuerda que nos vamos
a ir hasta el punto decimal bajamos el
siguiente cero recuerda que al menos nos
iremos hasta el punto decimal vamos a
subir este punto decimal es importante
tenerlo aquí al menos nos iremos hasta
el punto decimal o hasta que tengamos
cero o un patrón del número repetitivo
no hay sonó el teléfono pero no le haré
caso en este momento ustedes son más
importantes
adiós teléfono
ok así es que bajamos el c
30 entre 15 cabe dos veces 2 por 15 es
igual a 30 sea 30 le restó 30 tendré 0
pero sabemos que también hemos de bajar
el siguiente cero porque quedamos que al
menos nos iremos hasta el punto decimal
cuántas veces cabe 15 en 0 pues 0
0 por 15000 es igual a 0 y ahora sí
tenemos residuo igual a cero esta será
nuestra respuesta x
es igual a vamos a ponerle otro color
520 así es que si nos preguntan que 78
es el 15% de qué número la respuesta
será de 520
y tiene sentido porque porque si el 78
es el 15% es una porción muy pequeña es
un porcentaje pequeño así es que el
número total el 100 por ciento tendría
que ser un número mucho más grande y
tiene sentido 520 esta es la forma en la
que podemos conocer cuál es la base en
caso de que tengamos el monto el
porcentaje y nos pidan la base original
espero haber sido clara nos vemos en
otro vídeo